digamos que tenemos un vector que
llamaré un vector que llamaré a y este
vector es igual a 21 entonces puedo
dibujarlo por alcance iniciamos en el
origen me muevo dos espacios en el eje
horizontal a la derecha así hasta llegar
al 2 aquí después uno hacia arriba en el
en el eje vertical y este sería nuestro
vector ahora lo que quiero pensar es es
en cómo podemos definir la
multiplicación de este vector por un
escalar entonces por ejemplo si yo tengo
al escalar 3 tengo 3 y lo multiplicó por
el vector a entonces 3 x a esto es lo
mismo que 3
que multiplica al vector 21 entonces el
3 oro es un número y una manera de
pensar en esto aquí tenemos un número y
un vector y el vector este nos está
indicando una dirección y una magnitud
pero el 3 simplemente es un número así
que cómo puedo yo definir la
multiplicación de este número por este
vector tal vez podríamos pensar en bueno
simplemente multiplico el 3 por cada uno
de los componentes en el vector am
entonces tenemos tenemos 2 y 1 y
multiplicó a cada uno de estos por 3 nos
quedarían dos y uno y los multiplicó por
3 3 por 2 y 3 por 1 y el resultado el
vector resultante va a ser un vector de
dos dimensiones otra vez entonces al
multiplicar nos queda 6 y 3 de hecho
puede sacar papel milimétrico intenta
poner este vector y observa cómo se
relaciona con el vector original
entonces el vector 6,3
si iniciamos en el origen nos movemos
seis espacios en el eje horizontal
entonces 1 2 3 4 5 6 y después 3 en la
dirección vertical aquí este es el
vector el punto 6 3 y el vector quedaría
así ahora ok que acaba de pasar que que
le pasó al vector nota que ok nota que
ha cambiado y que no ha cambiado lo que
no ha cambiado es la dirección cierto
entonces tiene la misma dirección la
misma dirección este vector que el
vector original multiplicar por un
escalar no cambió la dirección del
vector en este caso pero observa que si
cambio algo y eso es un magnitud su
magnitud ahora es tres veces mayor
cierto lo cual lo cual tiene sentido
porque yo multiplique a este vector por
tres entonces puedes pensar al vector
este número escalar este es el número
escalar lo que hizo fue aumentar la
magnitud del vector incrementar la
magnitud entonces el vector de estar con
una magnitud de 1
a cambio a tres hojas sin cambiar la
dirección del vector pero ahora vamos a
hacer algo interesante vamos a
multiplicar nuestro vector a por un
número un número negativo digamos menos
1 para hacer esto simplemente entonces
lo multiplicamos por menos 1 y entonces
ok el menos 1 multiplica el vector ay
cuando usando la convención que ya
tenemos sobre multiplicación de vectores
por escalares nos queda lo siguiente
menos 1 por 2 es igual a menos 2 menos
dos y menos uno por uno es igual a menos
uno así que nos queda menos dos coma
menos uno si iniciamos en el origen
entonces nos movemos dos espacios en el
eje horizontal ahí y después uno en el
eje vertical aquí está el punto este es
nuestro vector menos 2 - 1 como puedes
ver qué pasó con el vector cuando cuando
yo hice esto volteo la dirección al
multiplicar este vector por menos 1
cambio su dirección en la dirección
totalmente opuesta
pero no cambio la magnitud cierto
solamente la dirección lo cual tiene
mucho sentido tiene sentido que al
multiplicar por un número negativo
hiciera eso que lo cambiara de dirección
de hecho en la recta numérica es lo que
sucede si tú tomas por ejemplo el número
5 y lo multiplicas por menos uno te te
va a llevar en la dirección opuesta
menos al menos 55 espacios a la
izquierda del cero cierto entonces tiene
sentido que cambie su dirección ahora
podrías por ejemplo imaginar si si tomas
por ejemplo al menos 2 y lo multiplicas
por el vector am que va a suceder que
como se va a mirar este vector entonces
tenemos esto será igual el menos 2
multiplica al 2 primero menos 2 por 2 es
igual a menos 4 y menos 2 por uno es
igual a menos 2 entonces este vector si
iniciamos en el origen nos movemos 4
espacios en el eje horizontal pero a la
izquierda aquí después dos espacios en
el eje vertical entonces menos 4 como
menos 2 se mira así este efector se mira
así y sólo como recordatorio
el vector original el vector a que es
igual a 21 se miraba así cierto pero
aquí está aquí no están en el origen y
el vector ha multiplicado por 2 se mira
se mira así ahora un vector no siempre
debe estar en el origen por eso estoy
haciéndolo de esta manera para que te
des cuenta de eso el vector menos 4 coma
menos 2 se mira así y puedes ver que
tiene sentido totalmente opuesto ajá al
vector original y el doble de magnitud
si lo hubiéramos x menos 1 al vector a
simplemente tendría la dirección opuesta